[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es wieder ein leckeres rezept
für den ramadan meine zuschauer also ihr
habt euch gewünscht dass ich auch
rezepte macher die man so war
vorbereiten kann
die man dann eben am abend zum iftar
also zum fastenbrechen essen kann und
das gericht wenn sich martin gretschmann
ist eine provinz in der türkei in
südostanatolien
und dieser eindruck für steht aus
lammfleisch auberginen tomaten und
paprika richtig lecker und vor allem
könnt ihr es wirklich supergut
vorbereiten ich zeige euch mal die
zutaten die ich benutze fürs landgericht
verwende ich 500 gramm aubergine 250
gramm grüne spitz paprika tomaten ein
kilogramm fleisch 50 gramm butter 20 km
sonnenblumenöl einem esslöffel paprika
markt eine zwiebel 1 knoblauchzehe salz
pfeffer ein lorbeerblatt und kreuzkümmel
zuerst nämlich jetzt die aubergine und
da schneide ich vorne den kopf weg den
stehen hinten auch und dann schneide ich
sehr einfach in etwa 2 cm große würfel
[Musik]
dann lege ich sie in entzieht und
betreue sie mit salz so zieht das salz
einfach die bitterstoffe und etwas
flüssigkeit drauf und ich kann dann so
etwa eine halbe stunde stehen lassen und
in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
zwiebel schälen die knoblauchzehe
schälen
beides fein würfeln
[Musik]
reitemann übrigens immer gerne alles
erstmal zu bevor ich an den herd gehen
meine mama hat immer direkt in den herd
gibt also in den topf gekocht fand ich
ehrlich sagt immer wieder umständlich
karmann sparte geschehe weil man einfach
keine kleinen schälchen hat aber man
kann eben auch was vergessen und was
falsch machen
deswegen rate ich immer dazu immer erst
mal das gemüse und fleisch schneiden und
vorbereiten und dann an den herd gehen
außer man hat eben das was man parallel
machen kann die spitz paprika da nie
etwas 2 bis 3 cm große stücke schneiden
wenn ich jetzt für mich alleine kochen
würde dann würde ich die scharfen nehmen
aber die sind jetzt mit alle mit essen
können schärfen kam er danach noch und
hier habe ich jetzt das lammfleisch und
habe ich jetzt das fleisch aus der keule
genommen ohne knochen direkt und jetzt
schneide ich das auch in würfel die
dürfen etwa 3 bis 4 cm groß sein
[Musik]
das fleisch habe ich jetzt auch schon
vor einer halben stunde aus dem
kühlschrank genommen damit einfach nicht
mehr so kalt ist wird auch gleich
angebraten und ich kann jetzt auch schon
mal in meinem gusseisernen topf die
butter und das öl erhitzen und ich mich
da immer gerne butter und öl damit
einfach die butter nicht verbrennt das
war so ein tipp jungen aber ich habe
jetzt absichtlich ein stück genommen wo
einfach ein bisschen fett dran ist denn
das fed sorgt dafür dass das fleisch
nicht austrocknet und ist natürlich auch
geschmacksträger deswegen schneide ich
das jetzt hier auch gar nicht weg
jetzt ist das fett heiß und jetzt gebe
ich das fleisch immer portionsweise rein
und nehmens damit daraus gerade es
vorher einfach schön rundherum an und so
bekomme ich tolle röstaromen und kann
späteres fleisch an den backofen weiter
schmoren
das fleisch ist es rundherum angebraten
und rausgenommen jetzt gebe ich hier ins
restliche feld einfach die zwiebel und
knoblauch wirken rein und die brate ich
dann bei mittlerer stufe so etwa vier
bis fünf minuten an
würde ich jetzt einfach den deckel drauf
die auberginen sind jetzt auch soweit
die kann ich jetzt unter klarem wasser
abspülen und auf brücken
so kann ich das salz noch mal ein
bisschen wegwaschen
das bibel sind jetzt auch schon so weit
da kommt jetzt die paprika dazu
die auberginen mit rein
eine wolldecke situation
kurz mit anbraten
die tomaten habe ich jetzt auch bereits
gewirbelt die gebe ich jetzt aufgezogen
gemeinsam mit dem fleisch
kann ich mir hat auch schon mal
ausschalten gibt es caprica markt noch
mit rein und fühle hier so etwa vier bis
500 milliliter wasser noch auch erst mal
am anfang lieber nicht so viel damit
einfach nicht zu flüssig wird die
gewürze füge ich jetzt noch dazu das
lorbeerblatt dem kreuzkümmel mein papa
hat immer gesagt wer mit lamm kocht muss
immer kreuzkümmel nehmen zum würzen dann
etwas salz und pfeffer und das ist
wirklich etwas was ihr super gut
vorbereiten könnt gerne auch morgens
dann einfach den deckel drauf dann darf
es für etwa ein bis eineinhalb stunden
im backofen weiter schmoren
ich lasse es gerne auch zwei stunden
oder länger drin weil es einfach dann
echt noch zarter wird wenn ihr möchtet
dass die aubergine gern noch ein
bisschen fester bleibt dann gebt die
erst ganz zum schluss dazu eine halbe
stunde vorher
ich mag es aber auch ganz gerne wenn die
ganz weich sind das ist wirklich ein
gericht was man super gut auch für die
ramadan zeit vorbereiten kann
vor allem wenn man abend keine lust mehr
hat in der küche zu stehen morgens
vorbereiten dann im backofen stellen und
dann kurz vor dem essen zu zwei stunden
vorher einfach kurz anschalten
[Musik]
jetzt ist das gericht fertig das gab es
auch kurz bisschen abkühlen lassen damit
es nicht brot und reis ist und ihr seht
richtig schön
das lorbeerblatt muss man natürlich
entfernen und ich habe eben schon
probiert und jetzt könnt ihr es entweder
mit fladenbrot anrichten so wie ich sie
jetzt heute mache oder richtet zum
beispiel mit türkischem reisen oder mit
kartoffel mit kartoffelpüree oder
einfach so als eintopf sowie ihr gerne
möchte und was ich am liebsten mache ist
brot ein tor und dann schön von der soße
nation was ich bei meinem eigenen teller
noch machen werde ist hubert drauf geben
also chiliflocken damit auch ein
bisschen scharf wird aber die kinder
essen er bei uns immer mit die ersten
nicht so scharf wie ich deswegen was ich
da weg das ganze ist wirklich super wird
sich um sehr lecker murat ist leider
geraten und ich da zum probieren
also solltet ihr das rezept einfach mal
selbst ausprobieren dann wisst ihr auch
wie es schmeckt und ich wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen eine
richtig schöne ramadan zeit und schreibt
mir gerne in die kommentare was ihr noch
sehen möchtet also bis bald
[Musik]